a Las Vegas city councilwoman is suing  another Las Vegas city councilwoman  claiming that she physically assaulted  her talking about Republican Victoria  Seaman who you see there she is suing  fellow Republican Michelle Fiore she  says fiori broke her finger and threw  her to the floor in January 2021. Seaman  says this happened at City Hall and in  the lawsuit claims that when she tried  to report it the mayor and the city  dismissed her concerns  Seaman also says the city destroyed  video of the altercation the lawsuit  asks for monetary damages asks for Fiore  to resign and more safety measures at  City Hall Fiore has not immediately  commented on the lawsuit just yet